piece by piece this project is coming
together to ultimately become home for
23 year old Monica I'm very excited it's
very surreal to be a part of this
process
Monica is a local resident who has had a
challenging past at times she was living
in her car and has asked her identity be
concealed now her life taking a turn for
the better as she was selected by
Habitat for Humanity to become the
beneficiary of a New Home Project Monica
has to complete 300 Sweat Equity hours
and so what that means she has to
contribute her own labor and time out
here on the construction site working
alongside our donors and Volunteers in
lieu of giving us a down payment for her
home Monica's 800 square feet
two-bedroom two-bath residence is part
of a 20-unit project in Henderson
featuring a smart security system and
rooftop solar donated by ADT a complete
package which they say will help protect
her from crime and cut utility costs we
don't want to build large-scale homes
that may have high utility costs more
property tax things like that our homes
are truly affordable for our homeowners
we're going to be putting some drywall
up or putting some plywood up on the
ceilings today ADT employees were among
several volunteers building the home
home to help get Monica back on her feet
this whole process has been it's still
been sinking in but I don't know this is
probably the first night I'll just be
happy to enjoy my home and just sit
around and soak it all in